the first time I became aware I think
you know I think we're we working on
Willow when you guys were doing while I
leave to be here was it something I
think was something like that yeah so I
mean we would share movie ollas you know
and and we would be waiting to get on
and and I would be waiting to look at
something and then John would bring
stuff and put it on while you D stuff
would come up yeah like come on okay
good luck guy and I have no idea where
it was gonna go I couldn't I didn't have
you know whatever it took to read it I
had no you know really any clue about
technology at all other than the
technology though you know we were
working with it at the time which was a
which was probably that kind of a weird
you know alchemical prehistoric version
of computer graphics it was like this
thing called film ocean which was a
basically a computer graphic I mean a
computer-driven puppet like a Bunraku
Japanese puppet that had like all these
x y&z servos on it and I'd like grown up
and trained myself in the craft to
stop-motion animation which is basically
yes sculpting movement in time where you
actually physically do creative
performance that starts and ends and
that's what it is you know you do it
over a 15 or 20 hour period and what you
end up with in film is the thing but as
the B movies of the 50s and the 60s you
know turned into the you know a movies
of the of the you know of late 70s in
the 80s it would kind of you know became
essential to try and figure out you know
some of the next steps that we could use
and they were pretty much handed to us
on a platter John Dykstra and Richard
Edlund had developed all the motion
control stuff right and for for Star
Wars and we just began you know plugging
in stop-motion puppets on a very similar
I mean a very simplistic level to that
just to get some kind of a motion blur
because Iraq it's like different than
yours I mean you're creating like whole
worlds and then what
we're doing is we're creating parts of
worlds that relate to earth specific
gravity and have to relate to
live-action performers and work
editorially within the context of a
theatrical feature film that's shot on
location someplace else and all the
complications that go along the back
that I won't get into but you know this
this go motion thing was an interim
device to try and achieve you know the
the effect of motion blur the the
artifact that you get when you run
something at 24
you know frames a second and it's
wiggling around you get this artifact
that's like a blur that kind of
equivocates and the person says you know
players don't really exist except on
film yeah I can't see a blur you know
it's just like yeah whatever and you
know so I it was I saw the wall-e the B
thing and it was just you know wasn't
part of my universe really you guys were
going someplace like I never expected
but my buddy Dennis Miran at ILM was you
know way ahead of the curve and started
you know getting wise what was going on
and they went through the historical
steps of you know taking the baby steps
and doing you know young Sherlock the
abyss you guys do some stuff on
Dragonslayer like remember that dragon
did he do some stuff on holy [ __ ] dragon
I mean it's really run know it was
pretend it's like those people in Paris
looking at the train coming at him and
running in a theatre that's what I felt
yeah there was no motion and all that
emotion stuff lasted for a historically
like it was like a blip you know between
stop-motion that had been there for like
you know the better part of you know
half a century and computer graphics you
know it was it was like this weird
little animals that lived for like you
know a million years and then died but
I'd tell I mean I you're paid it was
awesome I mean what you did with that
stuff it made these things for the first
time in stop-motion really was real I
mean it was this motion blur and that
Dragonslayer stuff so I'm seriously just
blew my mind and
all of us I mean I think it was really
one of the things that put it on the mat
was cast it was a pain in the ass
you